here's my solution to you on how to not  get canceled in today's times you ready  don't say a word don't text a single  word don't send an email don't have an  opinion have zero feelings if you ever  get angry don't make a look don't give a  smirk don't do anything people ask you  who did you vote for you say i don't  vote what do you think about trump i  don't have an opinion what do you think  about obama i don't have an opinion what  do you think what happened in  afghanistan i don't have an opinion do  you agree with aaron rodgers what he  said about him calling joe rogan on  ivermectin and he wants to do that i  don't have an opinion on whatever you do  just don't have an opinion because god  forbid if you do and you say single word  you'll be canceled but do you really  want to live that life